deep fakes are taking over Hollywood
look at this they now use deep fake
technology to change the lips of actors
so that they can have them speak other
languages and it looks totally natural
no more cheesy dubbing it's all going to
look really good here they are using it
to turn PG-13 rated movies into G-rated
movies and look at this Nicholas Cage is
talking to himself from 35 years ago
that's all deep fake technology in the
UK they even made an entire TV show with
deep faked celebrities in them these
aren't the real celebrities these are
random people with deep fake actors
faces on them look it's deep fake Idris
Elba living with deep faked Kim
Kardashian in some London estate that
show actually looks really good I think
we should check it out